cyber attack against the ukraine yeah i
know the nfc said it was too soon to
attribute the attack but could you say
where early indications are pointing
well uh let me first say that um
the and just because i know there's been
a lot of questions understandably on
this so let me try to address a few of
them as well if that's okay
the united states and our allies and
partners are concerned about this cyber
attack and the president has been
briefed we are also in touch with
ukrainians and have offered our support
as ukraine investigates the impact in
nature and recovers from the incidents
we don't have attribution at this time
and i can't point to any more specifics
i know the ukrainians also announced and
conveyed that they got their systems up
and running pretty quickly and that
personal data was not accessed we will
continue
to of course work with them and assess
any additional impacts we're continuing
to consult with allies and and partners
including ukraine on this you might have
also seen nato's statement as well which
says that they are also exchanging
information uh with ukraine so that's
where the status stands right now i
think it's important to note the
ukrainian statements on this which
convey very very clearly that they were
able to get their systems up and running
the u.s has information that indicates
russia has pre-positioned a group of
operatives to conduct a false flag
operation in eastern ukraine as reported
by cnn yeah i do have some detail on
this let me confirm for you
um
uh so as as you all have heard us say
many times uh we are concerned that the
russian government is preparing for an
invasion in ukraine that may result in
widespread human rights violations and
war crimes should diplomacy fail to meet
their objectives as part of its plans
russia's laying the groundwork to have
the option of fabricating a pretext for
invasion and we've seen this before we
saw this before leading up to 2014 just
to note
including through sabotage activities
and information operations by accusing
ukraine of preparing an imminent attack
against russian forces in eastern
ukraine
and the russian military plans to begin
these activities several weeks before a
military invasion which could begin
between mid-january and mid-february
again we saw this playbook before
including the widespread effort
to push out misinformation not just in
eastern europe but around the global
community we have information that
indicates russia has already
pre-positioned a group of operatives to
conduct a false flag operation in
eastern ukraine the operatives are
trained in urban warfare and in using
explosives to carry out acts of sabotage
against russia's own proxy forces our
information also indicates that russian
influence actors are already starting to
fabricate ukrainian provocations in
state and social media to justify a
russian intervention and so divisions in
ukraine for example russian officials
and influence actors are emphasizing
narratives about the deterioration of
human rights in ukraine and the
increased militancy of ukrainian leaders
this is all the spreading of
misinformation these media narrative
narratives also blame the west for
escalating tension highlight
humanitarian issues in ukraine that
russian intervention could solve and
promote russian patriotism to encourage
domestic support for military
action and finally during december
russian language content on social media
covering all three of these narratives
increased to an average of nearly 3 500
posts per day a 200 percent increase
from the daily average in november so
it's important to note what people are
seeing out there and to call out this
misinformation that is being spread to
uh
as a false flag operation and there's a
number of tactics that they're using in
that regard let me go to the back go
ahead thank you john
russia's foreign minister sergey lavrov
said today that moscow have run out of
patience
with the west so how passionate is
president biden with russia's aggressive
behavior
and another one
the afp
news agency reports that ukraine
proposes three-way crisis summit with
president biden putin and zelinski's
are you open to such a format
i have nothing to preview in terms of
the next steps on on negotiations or
talks uh everybody's back in their
capitals now having conversations about
that i will note that the president's
view in our view is that this is up to
president putin and russia to determine
what the path for it is we are ready
regardless of what they decide if they
decide they're going to invade ukraine
they're going to be economic
consequences that go far beyond 2014. if
they decide they want to engage in
diplomatic conversations and talks we
are very open to that and we're hopeful
they will do that but ultimately it's a
choice they need to make and so i would
suggest you ask them that question go
what about the president biden's
patience with uh what russia is again
it's not about that it's about russia
deciding what path they're going to take
[Music]
is
a